- how you doing - spades it's for these
waters
we're gonna grill the steaks on these
yeah
next we're gonna put them on the heat
now to sterilize Wow let's go let's go
let's go I'm letting dad take over for
once because that fire is mighty hot -
Lee if this works
it'd be a great idea right let's put
them in he was sitting on the outside of
the fire what's in the temple so after
two sets got loads of vegetables in said
the packages cook for about 10 minutes
there we go guys time to find out if you
can cook great food without pots and
pans sometimes it is great to have that
around temperatures dad loving it on
that if you're thinking of cooking
steaks on spades in a fire your
grown-ups would like to know about it or
maybe just use a frying pan I'm gonna
flip them I think the space burning
so maybe next time we should soak the
wood on his face
the stakes are perfect
and the ratatouille is ready too right
ready for the moment we've all been
waiting for to carve these babies let's
go I just love food so much we're always
arguing about it first
medium-rare hello
I love these good job today
mistake is good campfire cooking rules
okay
delicious I can't believe how you cook
them like that took it out back there's
something quite nice about eating food
in the deserts please don't make me
sleep out here
there's too many snakes and spiders I'd
like to camp out here there we are
proper come around